let's have a look at question 12 which
is a pretty pretty standard trig
question in fact
they tell you about about a triangle
they don't show it to you
which by the way if you can you if
you're having a look at someone's paper
and there's no diagram on there
the first thing i would like you to
write is no diagram
question mark expression exclamation
mark like why would you not draw a
diagram
for this because when they don't give
that to you
part of what they're determining is do
you have the spatial reasoning to work
out what on earth is happening
okay they tell you about this triangle
and then they give you some fact
a couple angles and a side so let's try
to build this thing together okay
now what i'm going to do is being that
it's not necessarily going to need to be
precise i'm going to draw a triangle
that looks vaguely
uh in in sort of the right dimensions
okay
and uh it's called abc so i'm just going
to call this a
this b this c if there's no diagram on
the paper
that you're marking please draw
something roughly equivalent to this
and then i'm going to start to supply
information that's been provided to me
onto the diagram
okay so we get an angle it's 30 degrees
where does it go on my diagram
on my diagram okay where does it go abc
abc that's the one at
b right remember it's like this back to
u seven how do we name angles right
so uh 30 degrees 30 degrees fantastic so
there's 30.
the next angle they give us is 45.
what's the name of that angle acb so
it's the one on the top okay so let's
pop that in as 45
and then they give us a length from
memory it's eight centimeters where's
that
ac so that's this guy over here on the
left hand side
and then the question they ask us is
determine the length of
a b so that's this guy down here now i
could give it another letter
x but you know what i can just call it a
b like a b is a way to describe it
i don't need to add more notation i'd
rather have as little as i can okay
now you have a look at the information
that's presented to you which
piece and i'm already telling you it's
trigonometry but which piece of
trigonometry is going to help us here
the signal fantastic how can you tell
sorry what was the clue
um you're missing one side so that
typically the questions
have one side missing and one full
equation fantastic so you can actually
look if
if this is like not triggering things in
your brain right you can look at the
reference sheet
you've got the cosine rule there you've
got the sine rule
we would usually write the sign rule
something like this uh
a on sine a equals b
on sine b that this might be a way in
fact i can't
maybe it's upside down on the reference
something like that right okay now you
can see here
that the knowns and unknowns fit
perfectly into
what the sine rule presents to us right
and i kind of look at it
as a shape some of you might even have
done this on your diagram can you see
there's an
angle and it's opposite unknown side
like so and then you have another angle
and it's opposite the
unknown side so this sort of crossover
shape is your big clue
to use the sine rule okay now before i
start to launch into things i know i'm
finding out
a b is there anything else in the
question that i should be aware of
any important stuff very good exact
value so this is not going to come in
until later
but it is going to affect the way that i
solve the question okay so
let's start maybe you're checking to see
what kind of response there
the unknown is the thing you want to put
first because it makes it easier to
lessen rearranging
right so my unknown is a b divided by
what
sine well the angle opposite it
right so in that case it's 45 degrees
sine 45
equals and then i've got a known side
and a known angle so it's going to be 8
on sine 30 fantastic now if you have
your exact values up your sleeve right
you could do this
lickety split maybe you need another
reference sheet to help you uh sine 45
what is that
sine 45 degrees it starts with a one
it's one on one on root two thank you
and then this guy over here some thirty
come on this is like the easiest one
right
this is one over two it's a half
okay so from there once you've got these
numbers in place you can just
rearrange we should end up at eight root
two did you get that
give me a nod give me a shake give me
something who got eight route two well
who's marking a paper that has abrupt
two
no really really guys i picked this one
because it was the easy one did you
yeah okay all right that's is that
john's yeah way to go john okay so it
sounds like you need a bit of help
getting to that point let's let's go
further okay so i've got a
b on one on root two
and then i've got eight on a half
is that okay got to be quite tricky with
the careful with these tricky fractions
on fractions
that's why i've got so many brackets
flying around okay so then when i go
over to the right hand side because i
want a b to be the subject right
for starters 8 divided by a half how
many halves are in 8 the answer is
two halves are false so this sounds like
y only john got
a root two okay eight divided by a half
you could think about a bunch of
different ways you can think about it as
eight divided by a half you just do your
algorithm right you turn it into
multiplication and take a reciprocal
it's a times two right
um or you can say how many halves are in
eight well you're going to go
a half and then one and then one and a
half and then you're going to get up to
16 of them
right so i'm getting 16 that's that's
that part
but to get this over on the other side
i've got to
multiply by 1 on root 2.
is that ok so maybe we were caught by
the fact that there's just so many
fractions flying around
16 divided by root 2 you can break up 16
into think about this right this is 8
times
2 on root 2 but 2 divided by root 2
the definition of root 2 is that's root
2
right or if you wanted to think about it
this way 2
is just root 2 times root 2. is that
are you content with that so then you
can say cancel cancel and you're here
okay what with the units again
did you get did you get the right answer
i didn't do exact values
okay so there was a problem
so what did you punch into your
calculator
yeah you did this stuff okay so you've
got uh i'm guessing what
which is 1.4 ish so it's what did you
get
11.3 yeah which is which is right isn't
it but
not exact how many marks do you think
serene just out of curiosity how many
likes do you guys think saran would get
for that answer being that it is
actually equivalent to area two
one i i'd say one's a pretty good bet we
actually have the marking guidelines
over here
um so we can we can find out but because
they specify
it's an exact value you can see that's
actually one of the big things they're
trying to assess
okay with that
okay so this is really interesting right
now let's let's think about uh i'm going
to write down 6.8
question mark okay now i'm looking
at our diagram here and i can
immediately tell even though i'm not 100
sure where this has
come from i can immediately tell and i
want you to think about this because
this is an exam technique right
i can immediately tell this can't be
right if i got arrived at this answer i
know i've done something wrong earlier
on
okay and i wonder if you can work out
nothing to do
with all my working here i'm just
looking at the diagram again when i say
no diagram why
can anyone suggest me why 6.8 can't
possibly be the answer
what do you reckon this is the length
we're trying to find out a b right uh i
don't know how long it is
but i know for sure as john says it has
to be longer than this side how did how
did you know that
we got that from yeah very good the
angles right this is the whole point of
the sign rule in fact the whole point of
it is as the angle gets bigger
the corresponding side or i should say
the opposite side also gets bigger and
like just think about this right
can you just put your hands out in front
of you right and make an angle
okay just literally do this with me okay
if you imagine your two hands as like
the sides of a triangle
right as you increase the size of the
angle widen out your hands now right
the side that's opposite is like between
your index fingers do you see that
well clearly your side's getting bigger
yeah so if you can put your hands down
now because you look hilarious
if you've got a bigger angle over here
45 degrees
then this angle over here 30 degrees
it's got to be bigger than 8. i've done
something wrong i'm not sure what it is
yet
but something's going right we can check
it out